hello friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  exploring the question  how to maintain multiple languages now  polygons are awesome creatures  and the more languages they have under  their belt the better and faster they  learn for languages  but they have a problem it's more and  more difficult to maintain them so  here's my piece of advice  think about all the activities that you  engage in when it comes to  your own native language and replace  them with activities you do  in your foreign language or foreign  languages i for one  read newspapers in polish or watch the  news in french or russian  and engage in other activities in other  languages if you do that  your language learning is going to  become sustainable fun and your life is  going to be  much richer over and out